[Music]
here's your money briefing from Monday
March 13th I'm J.R Whalen for the Wall
Street Journal
most investors saw their retirement
accounts take a beating last year except
for one group gen Z people born after
the mid to late 90s so how do people in
their 20s and early 30s with relatively
little investing experience wind up
coming out ahead Ogie and edoyan from
the wsj's personal finance team joins us
to go through the numbers Hey oian thank
you very much for being with us thanks
for having me J.R so oen tallying up the
score for us how did gen Z investors do
compared to other groups yeah so
somewhat surprisingly the people at
Fidelity tell us that while the average
nest egg and Fidelity accounts lost 23
percent in 2022 gen Z workers born
between 1997 and 2012 posted a gain of
14 wow that's a pretty big spread that's
pretty remarkable considering the fact
that the S P 500 was down nearly 20
percent for the year so have gen Z do
that did they crack some kind of
investing code no it wasn't anything
like that it wasn't investment Savvy or
beginner's luck so much as the Good
Fortune of not actually having that much
money invested yet as the Market's
tanked and so they had an average
balance of about 6 000 compared with 103
900 for all retirement Savers with
Fidelity accounts oh so the less money
invested the less damage to be done
exactly
and you know oh yeah we saw sell-off
after sell-off on Wall Street in 2022 it
was not pretty and that could have
scared a lot of people away you know
they might have pulled money out or at
least dialed back the amount that they
were investing yeah it was definitely a
rough year in the market last year but
Americans don't seem deterred about 90
of investors in the 401K style
retirement plans administered by
Vanguard group maintained or increased
their savings rate last year so in my
reporting I've seen that Americans
across the board are really prioritizing
their savings accounts and when I spoke
with Folks at Fidelity they also
emphasized this particularly among gen Z
who has greater access to Internet
research related to finance and how to
kind of invest especially when it comes
to retirement and so they're seeing
particularly in this generation that's
growing in the workforce a real
commitment to those types of saving
plans yeah that's pretty significant
given the fact that this is all
happening up against a pretty
challenging economic climate yeah I mean
U.S consumers are definitely beginning
to show signs of financial stress
particularly in recent months credit
card balances are rising back to
pre-pandemic levels in some places and
savings that people were able to build
up during the pandemic the early years
have now declined and so almost 50
percent of Americans are showing that
their personal savings that they had
accumulated about a year ago are either
lower or completely depleted a lot of
that is because Americans were flush
with cash due to stimulus checks and now
a lot of that money has gone away all
right and so back to gen Z what types of
Investments do most people in this age
group have in the market so gen Z has a
lot of investments in the stock market
given that 84 percent of them had most
of their investments in Target date
funds those are portfolios that shift
from stocks to bonds as people age so
for workers in their 20s such portfolios
are heavily exposed to the stock market
and so what's the benefit of these
Target date funds and why are they
common among younger people Target date
funds allow people to stay invested
gradually over time and typically they
increase employee savings rate by one
percentage point a year until they reach
a cap that's often 10 or more gen Z
Savers benefited from automatic
enrollment into their 401ks as more
companies have default contribution
rates between three percent and six
percent which cause more of them to save
these automatic features oftentimes
remove hurdles in the way of saving and
investing especially in challenging
Economic Times where people are less
likely to hold on to savings having an
automated streamline process kind of
puts that money in the background and
not in the foreground of people's fines
so they're still saving even if they're
balancing their budgets on their own
interestingly enough when I spoke with
Folks at Fidelity they mentioned that
more often than not most of these gen Z
workers are not really even aware of how
much money is in their 401K accounts
they usually are just automatically
enrolled into the system so it makes it
completely seamless and really easy for
them to save compared to past
Generations alright that's the Wall
Street journal's oen adedoyan with us oh
yeah and thanks so much for joining us
thanks for having me Jr an extra money
briefing I'm J.R Whalen for the Wall
Street Journal
[Music]
foreign